[Musica]
[Applauso]
avrei potuto dire cose bellissime ma ho
sentito la parola cozza e ho perso
ho perso l'ispirazione
i molluschi bivalvi hanno avuto nella
storia dell'uomo sempre un ruolo molto
importante perché sono sempre stati una
fonte di sostentamento
a me piace pensare
che i primi ominidi circa un milione di
anni fa
potessero scegliere se andare a caccia a
mani nude o armati di sassi e bastoni
rischiando la vita oppure scendere in
riva al mare o un fiume o un lago e
cercare i molluschi che erano e sono una
fonte di cibo disponibile pronta alla
quale non va somministrato
mangime o alimento ma si alimentano da
soli e
diciamo
appunto i molluschi hanno seguito la
storia evolutiva dell'uomo salto
tutta la storia perché sennò facciamo
facciamo sera e arrivo ai giorni nostri
da un lato abbiamo le
potenze le lobby
del sud occidentale che investono in
allevamenti intensivi di bestiame
dovete sapere che l'allevamento
intensivo
della carne influisce per il 14,5 per
cento e nel gas serra
invece la cina
ha fatto sta facendo una politica
completamente diversa la cina il più
grosso produttore di ostrica al mondo
ovviamente come in tutti i campi però
sta facendo un'operazione di sì grabbing
cioè sta prendendo mare sta acquistando
mare per esempio lungo le coste
dell'africa perché sta piantando
allevamenti estensivi dei molluschi
soprattutto di ostriche perché deve dare
da mangiare
ai cinesi quindi proteine di alta
qualità di alto valore senza
somministrare cibo e mangime questo è un
aspetto molto importante perché anche
dal punto di vista economico
diciamo ha degli effetti
molto molto positivi ma il valore e il
ruolo dei molluschi bivalvi nella storia
oltre dell'uomo soprattutto del pianeta
terra e anche e anche un'altra è un
valore molto un ruolo molto più grande
di quello che siamo portati a pensare
perché i molluschi bivalvi per
accrescere la loro conchiglia
sintetizzano carbonato di calcio
sottraendolo dal fitoplancton filtrano
l'acqua di mare come potete immaginare
loro vivono filtrando acqua di mare per
cibarsi respirare e
e quindi sintetizzano il carbonato di
calcio per accrescere la conchiglia il
mare per mantenere un equilibrio
dinamico delle ioni carbonato cosa fa
sottrae co2 dall'atmosfera
quindi è evidente che i molluschi
bivalvi sono un sistema attivo di
cattura e sequestro definitivo della co2
che viene inglobata immagazzinata
definitivamente dentro i gusci quando
gli animali o muoiono vengono mangiati
vengono consumati in qualsiasi qualsiasi
modo il loro gusci rimangono e vanno a
formare i depositi carbonatici le
dolomiti le alpi apuane sono il frutto
di un accumulo di carbonato di calcio
che da 600 milioni di anni a questa
parte
va avanti e ovviamente il ruolo dei
molluschi bivalvi è stato anche un ruolo
attivo nel cambiare l'atmosfera perché
comunque togli co2 oggi ti togli co2
domani hanno modificato hanno
contribuito a modificare l'atmosfera
rendendola
vivibile per gli esseri gli esseri
terrestri gli esseri viventi e
diciamo che
sono state fatte anche delle stime e a
questo proposito si è formato un gruppo
di lavoro che si chiama blu carbon sink
che è un gruppo al quale partecipano i
mitilicoltori che rappresento ama che
l'associazione mediterranea acquacoltori
l'enea la dabliu sense che è una start
up una spin off dell'università la
sapienza di roma
carbon sink srl che è una società
specifica in questo campo con la
supervisione scientifica del professor
ravagnan lo scopo qual è lo scopo è
quantificare la co2 che viene sottratta
con l'allevamento dei mitili con la
mitilicoltura e generare dei carbon
credits e
certificarli per poter essere
monetizzati e
venduti perché dico venduti perché
purtroppo se una cosa non la rendi
vendibile non ha non ha valore quindi
non ha nemmeno quel non dà nemmeno
quell'incentivo per poter andare avanti
e noi abbiamo stimato con dei calcoli
specchio m c che la mitilicoltura in
italia ogni anno rimuover sequestra ed
elimina 19 mila tonnellate di co2
dall'atmosfera 19 mila tonnellate di co2
quando ho detto prima che gli
allevamenti intensivi
contribuiscono per il 14,5 per cento ei
gas serra cioè sono due mondi
completamente
differenti
ora voi
quindi quando mangiate un piatto di
vongole o di ostriche di muscoli
spaghetti allo scoglio e qualsiasi altra
qualsiasi altra cosa vi invito a
guardare i gusci con un'altra con
un'altra ottica dire o questa era co2 la
cosa strana lo dico con un
po di polemica è che l'italia una
nazione è completamente circondata dal
mare
però se voi guardate la televisione ora
siamo nell'epoca del nell'era del food
televisivo voi ogni programma televisivo
che guardate ogni ricetta contiene la
carne noi siamo invasi dalla carne ci
stanno facendo il lavaggio del cervello
sulla carli non voglio fare il l'anti
carne provi invita a pensare al fatto
che noi siamo una nazione che è
naturalmente proiettata sul mare e
purtroppo però questi dati che vi ho
detto non sono minimamente tenuti in
considerazione ed è per questo che noi
abbiamo creato questo gruppo di lavoro
che fortunatamente ha già avuto un
riscontro positivo dal ministero della
transizione ecologica che ci ha invitato
ad andare al al ministero poi per
esprimere esporre i dati che stiamo
raccogliendo anche perché una volta che
avremo messo appunto il meccanismo
questo meccanismo dei carbon credits lo
applicheremo a livello della
mitilicoltura
nazionale ed europea e lo so che è una
cosa un po diciamo
avveniristica che forse stiamo andando
anche oltre quello che sarebbe il nostro
ruolo di allevatori però ci siamo resi
conto che se non facciamo così purtroppo
non riusciamo ad andare avanti
perché perché ci siamo accorti facendo
analisi e studi in tutti questi anni che
il mare sta cambiando il clima the
change
evidente e sotto gli occhi di tutti gli
eventi atmosferici sono sempre più
violenti però paradossalmente quello che
ci fa più danno noi allevatori di
molluschi è l'incremento della
temperatura media del mare perché da un
punto di vista fisico quando la
temperatura del mare aumenta
l'ossigeno disciolto nel mare diminuisce
gli organismi acquatici sia i molluschi
bivalvi che anche i pesci e altri
organismi respirano ossigeno dal mare e
questo crea un problema a tutti quanti
allora noi abbiamo ideato lo stiamo
progettando ea breve lo realizzeremo un
punto chino
coperto di pannelli fotovoltaici
che alimentano un compressore che da
aria a dei diffusori di micro bolle dei
micro diffusori che fanno gorgogliare
dell'area micro bolle sotto agli
impianti di mitilicoltura
questo fa sì che quando l'ossigeno
diminuisce noi interveniamo e
ripristiniamo il
normale trofismo della colonna d'acqua
questo concetto di
generazione di
elettricità off grid a delle
applicazioni che possono spaziare in
tutti i campi in mare per infatti siamo
già stati contattati da delle realtà
anche locali che lo vogliono usare per
per altri scopi anche perché noi con la
dabliu sense abbiamo messo in mare
giusti giorni scorsi dei sensori arco
grid cioè sono dei sensori che
comunicano hanno delle batterie e
comunicano con un gateway a terra
tramite onde acustiche e quindi noi ora
in tempo reale siamo in grado di tramite
lo smartphone vedere in mezzo al mare
la situazione di temperatura ossigeno
corrente e tutti quei sensori che
vogliamo mettere per cui la nostra idea
è quella di
mettere
questi punticini negli impianti di
allevamento dei dei molluschi proprio
per favorire la
crescita dei molluschi però allo stesso
tempo favorire la conversione della co2
in carbonato di calcio quindi aumentare
il tasso di conversione di co2 e
aumentare carbon credits
parallelamente però sempre e lo dico
per aumentare la monetizzazione la
monetizzabili ta di questi carbon
credits abbiamo iniziato a eliminare
completamente la plastica nell'attività
della molluschicoltura le famose retine
calze tubolari reste chiamatele come
volete stiamo studiando nuovi materiali
abbiamo vinto un'importante life
ambiente e stiamo sperimentando delle
retine in amido di mais e iniziamo ora
la sperimentazione con dei materiali
fatti in canapa cioè tutto materiale bio
compostabile non biodegradabile
biocompostabili perché comunque
materiale che comunque poi una volta che
è stato utilizzato va preso e mandato a
compostaggio
questo è molto importante perché
comunque non utilizzando più plastica
aumenti la frazione netta di co2 che
recuperi
allo stesso modo
stiamo facendo studiando e lo faremo a
breve
abbiamo già dei modelli dei modelli di
barche pronte da da testare
cambiare la motorizzazione della della
molluschicoltura inshore cioè quella
sottocosta cambiarla da
normali combustibili fossili passare a
motorizzazione elettrica perché anche lì
con di tutto un discorso delle fonti
rinnovabili riusciamo comunque a andare
ad emissione zero
lo stiamo facendo tutto nell'ottica
ripeto di andare al ministero della
transizione ecologica
per
dire che noi siamo pronti per
confrontarci con gli strumenti come
diceva il sindaco quei soldi che
arriveranno per il pnr r per poter dire
che la molluschicoltura può dare un
contributo molto importante nel
rimuovere la co2
c'è chi vuol pompare co2 nei giacimenti
esausti di idrocarburi è una cosa che
non ha riscontri né scientifici né
ambientali e
crediamo che la risposta sia sia in un
in un altro in un altro modo
uno di questi modi per esempio a quello
che proponiamo noi anche perché in fin
dei conti il più grande serbatoio di
co2 è il mare proprio come serbatoio
ricevente per cui noi il nostro scopo
quale è quello di
salvare il mare per salvare il pianeta
terra ovverosia diamo un respiro al mare
per dare un respiro la terra per cui vi
invito a
mangiare più muscoli e più ostriche
grazie
[Applauso]